YURI GRINSHTEYN: Hi, everyone,
and welcome to Google Cloud
Next On Air.
Today we're going to be
talking about some best
practices for monitoring
user experience
and for using custom metric
telemetry to do so on Google
Cloud using cloud monitoring.
My name is Yuri Grinshteyn.
I'm a site reliability
engineer here at Google Cloud.
I'm part of the Customer
Reliability engineering team.
I have the good
fortune and pleasure
of being joined by Mike
Debreceni from Niantic.
Mike, thank you so
much for being here.
MICHAEL DEBRECENI: Thank you.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
today we're going
to cover three main areas.
First, I'm really
excited to talk to Mike
about the experience that
he's had actually putting
this stuff into
real life, putting
this stuff into production.
So we're going to talk
about what they've
done to monitor user experience,
focus on service health,
and how they've really
implemented some of that stuff.
From there, we're going to get
into how you might actually
start moving on this
journey yourself
by first creating some basic
availability and latency SLO's
using Google Cloud monitoring.
And from there,
I'm going to dive
into some best practices for
implementing customer service
level indicators using
custom metrics long-term.
So with that said,
let's get into it.
First, Mike, thank you
so much for being here.
Would you mind
starting by telling
us a little bit about Niantic
architecture and scale
and your role there?
MICHAEL DEBRECENI: Absolutely.
So I am a site reliability
engineer with Niantic.
I'm actually the
first dedicated SRE
and have been with the
company for about three years.
When Pokemon Go launched,
I wasn't with Niantic yet,
but I was definitely
an avid player.
I was fascinated by
some of the growth
and scaling challenges at launch
and decided, this is awesome.
I want to be part of this.
So after I joined
Niantic, I helped
launch some of the social
features, including the friends
and creating features
for Pokemon, the ability
to send GIFs, and
also the weather
features that help with respond
rates and so on for Pokemon.
I'm currently the lead SRE on
the Harry Potter Wizards Unite
title and support
several back end services
and monitoring that are used
by current and future titles.
Our games are enjoyed by
millions of players worldwide.
I'm going to be a little
bit vague about scale,
but I will say that we do have
a large number of players.
We have players that want
to play the game 24/7.
They want the game to work
whenever and wherever they
decide to play.
We run on the Google
Cloud platform
and make heavy use of the
Kubernetes engine, Spanner,
Data Flow, Cloud Load Balancer,
and several other GCP services.
Our architecture is
somewhere between monolithic
and a microservice model.
We have games that consist of
several discrete components,
including the front end server
and several back-end services
to support the games.
So the front end servers
take care of things
like keeping track of the
game state, player activity,
keeping track of game rules.
The back-end services
take care of things
such as supporting our spatial
database, player account
registry, and then some of
the social features-- again,
the gifting and friend lists.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All
right, thank you.
So one of the things you
just mentioned were services.
So tell me about
how do you monitor
the health of these services?
MICHAEL DEBRECENI:
When I started,
we were using a traditional
monitoring approach.
So a combination of Prometheus
and Google Cloud Monitoring.
We actually like the way that
the two worked together quite
nicely, and so we support both.
The traditional
monitoring approach
means that you pick
a set of metrics
that you think represent how
well the system is working.
So this will be a mix of system
metrics like memory and CPU use
and then game-level
metrics that might
be things like how many
Pokemon are being captured.
How many spells are being cast?
How many players are logged in?
You then set
thresholds for normal
and then watch for
things that indicate
something unusual is going on.
So maybe we see that the number
of players has dropped off
or the number of
successful Pokemon copters
has suddenly dropped off.
And this works fairly well.
There are some limitations
to this approach.
So number one, it tells you
how the servers are doing,
but it doesn't necessarily tell
you how the players are doing.
There's some guesswork involved
in picking the correct metrics
and figuring out
which metrics matter.
Also picking appropriate
thresholds so that you end up
with alerts that are
sensitive, but not so sensitive
that they're to the
point of being noisy.
It's very, very easy to
focus on wrong metrics,
and it's very easy
to miss problems
that may involve a combination
of metrics that combine
in ways you never anticipated.
One of the things
that we learned
is that distributed systems tend
to fail in very complex ways.
With Wizards Unite, we piloted
a SLO monitoring approach
with the help of our
partners at Google
to complement our
traditional monitoring.
So the approach here
is to look at the game
from the point of
view of players
rather than the servers.
So we measure things
like request latency,
the success rate for requests
from players, both overall,
and then a more detailed level,
such as the individual actions
that they may
perform in the game.
We then set performance
targets for these metrics,
and end up with service
level objectives, or SLOs.
We can then I'll
subtract error budgets
based on how well we
stick with these SLOs
and how well we comply
over the long term.
We then alert based
on absolute violations
or if we start burning
error budget excessively.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Makes sense.
So it sounds like some
of the primary reasons
you're adopting SLOs is to
really focus on user experience
and how users are
perceiving the game.
Was that the primary motivation?
And then what other
benefits did you
see from making this change?
MICHAEL DEBRECENI: So there
are a couple of benefits.
So as we realized, players
are not really interested
with the details of our server.
They do care if the
game is working, though,
so we should measure that.
So what we found is
that by implementing
a couple of very simple SLOs
based off of the metrics
from our load balancer,
latency and success rate,
we're able to tell a lot
about the player experience.
They also keep us very
honest because we're not
depending on the servers to
report their own metrics.
One of the things, obviously,
is that if a server crashes,
it's not going to
report anything
that says it's in trouble.
Something else has to do that.
So the effect of this is that
problems have nowhere to hide.
If there's something
going on whether it's
something internal
within the server
or something with our
network infrastructure,
we're going to see it
as an SLO violation
if it affects the players, and
then we'll receive an alert.
So some of the benefits.
We tend to see better
quality alerts.
We have much less alert noise
with our SLO violation alerts.
We do know that when
we get an alert,
we know that there's
something going on
that we need to address.
The alert doesn't necessarily
tell us what the problem is,
but it does let us know
that we need to start
our troubleshooting process.
And this is where we may
look at some of our existing
traditional monitoring.
It's also actually
taught us a couple
of things about our
deployments that we've done
and some of the regressions
that may come up afterwards.
So we found that by watching
outside of the servers,
we can now see the
effect of doing
even things like a deployment
or planned maintenance.
This means that we've
actually changed the way
that we do some of
our deployments based
on some of the
observed disruption
that we were causing.
The other thing
that we've noticed
is that we can watch for what's
called a slow burn alert, where
we're very slowly
consuming error budget,
but faster than we should be.
This would be something like
a slow leak in a car tire
where you may not notice that
there is a problem from day
to day, but you will
definitely notice
when you have a flat tire.
So what this is, it's
watching the cumulative effect
of small SLO violations
that may start
after we've made some change.
This would be lost in the noise
of a traditional monitoring
approach.
But with our slow monitoring
and our error budget tracking,
they're now very visible.
And now we know,
again, that we need
to start looking
for a regression.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
this sounds great.
Now you have a better
sense of user experience.
Your alerts are
of higher quality.
When you get an
alert, you actually
know that there's a problem.
You can also catch problems
like the slow burn situation
that you described.
So this all sounds great.
What's been the hardest part
about making this transition
and making this change?
MICHAEL DEBRECENI: I think
selling the idea internally
was actually one of
the harder things.
A lot of people understand
what traditional monitoring is,
but they don't understand
necessarily why we also
want to do SLO monitoring.
Why isn't traditional
monitoring good enough?
So I had to explain that
this is a complement
to traditional monitoring.
We're not replacing our
existing monitoring;
we're just adding to it.
We're doing something
that means that we're
looking at the same metric
data, but in a different way
and interpreting it differently.
One of the benefits
that we realized
is, again, detecting problems
that we didn't even see coming.
The other obstacle
that I ran into
is the conception that
SLOs are just for SREs,
and nobody else needs
to pay any attention.
And actually this
is not the case.
We definitely need and want
input from product and the rest
of the business.
As SREs, we're very good
at measuring things.
Product is very good at knowing
what we need to be measuring
and what we need
to be looking for.
Unfortunately, the product
team is also very busy,
and unless they
understand their role
in coming up with good SLOs,
it's hard to get their time.
So the approach we
took was to make
this as easy as possible
by focusing on one or two
starter SLOs where we
had a pretty good idea
and just needed
confirmation from product.
Once we had that and could
demonstrate some value,
we were then able to
bring in product and work
on some more advanced SLOs.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So selling
this internally is a challenge.
Getting product to buy
into is a challenge.
So that's something that
makes a lot of sense.
I totally get that.
Looking back on your
journey, would you
have done anything differently?
Or what would you
do differently?
MICHAEL DEBRECENI: So one of the
things that I would have done
is to start simple, demonstrate
value quickly, and focus
on the quick wins
before taking on some
of the more advanced use cases.
So as an example, one of
the things we tried to do
was set up SLOs based off of the
custom metrics in Prometheus.
This involves setting up a
sidecar, which ingests metrics,
and to Stackdriver.
We had some concerns about the
cardinality of that metric,
of the metrics
that we were using,
and wanted to
pre-summarize the data
before sending it in to the
cloud monitoring service.
We found that that was actually,
at the time, fairly difficult,
because the sidecar was in a
fairly early development state
compared to where it is now.
So we ended up working
with the development
team behind the sidecar
and were eventually
able to add the
feature that supports
aggregated metrics coming in.
This was a huge help for us.
It let us do what we want.
And the sidecar is now
in a much better state.
However, it did take a
long time to get something.
Looking back, I would
have just started
with the load balancer metrics.
They actually gave us
something useful very
quickly in about an
afternoon's work.
And that gave us about 90%
of what we were looking for.
They were also much,
much simpler to set up.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, I can understand
that, just using the out-of-box
load balancer metrics,
rather than kind of building
it along with Prometheus
and then also maintaining
that additional side car
infrastructure.
Yeah, would certainly
make things a lot easier.
So that's an excellent
lesson to pass on
to the folks that are looking
to start their journey down
this path as well.
Other than that,
what else would you
advise someone who is looking
to follow in your footsteps
and reproduce this?
MICHAEL DEBRECENI: So I
would say, don't be afraid.
This is actually not
that hard to set up.
Like I said, with the
load balancer metrics,
we had something
in an afternoon.
It was very straightforward.
The other thing I would say
is that if you can measure it,
you can turn it into an SLO.
So think about the existing
metrics that you already have
and see if there
are ways that you
can turn them into an SLO that
describes user experience.
Obviously there are some
that will work very well.
In our case, the load balancer
metrics were very helpful.
They were free.
They were available
out of the box.
Don't forget, also,
to start simple and go
with a quick and easy
win before taking
on the more advanced
challenges that may
need some buy-in from others.
Finally, pick the right tools.
Pick a tool that's flexible
and that works well
with your existing environment.
In our case, we chose the cloud
monitoring SLO API from Google.
This supports creating
many types of SLOs,
works on all cloud
platforms, and supports
containerized and virtual
machine environments.
We're very happy with how
it's worked out for us.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
And again, thanks
for being here.
I think this is some
super useful lessons
that I think you have learned
that I'm very happy that you're
able to pass on to others.
So thank you very much, again.
From here, what
I'd love to do is
to walk through some practical
examples of how folks
are watching this session
and take some of the lessons
that Mike has learned and apply
them to your own environment.
First, I want to show you how to
do exactly what Mike is saying.
How do you create some of
those basic availability
and latency SLOs using some
of the out of the box features
in Google Cloud Monitoring?
They're there for you to
use without really the need
to do any additional
application instrumentation.
The way this works is
that you essentially
have to start by
defining your service.
The basic premise here is
that you have a service,
and you can be
measuring service health
using service-level
objectives for that service.
There are two primary ways
by which you can define
the service using the UI.
If your service is running
on Google Kubernetes Engine
or GKE, the UI will
actually let you
pick one of the GKE primitives
to essentially create
this logical construct which
you can use as a service.
So you can use things
like GKE services,
GKE deployments, even
something like a GKE namespace,
and tie your service
definition to that.
If your GKE cluster
has Istio installed
on it, which is an open
source service mesh that
allows you to do things like
traffic routing, security
encryption, and telemetry
or observability,
then its services running
within the Istio service mesh
will also be exposed
for you here,
and you can simply
pick one of those.
That's the first step, to select
a service that's already been
defined or define it yourself.
If you're not running
on GKE, if you actually
want to define just
a custom service,
there's an API available that
you can use to do that as well.
So that's the first step
is, select the service
or define the service.
The next step would
be to pick the SLI.
SLI stands for service
level indicator,
and this is the metric
that you're actually
going to use to essentially
determine, at any given point,
is your service healthy or not.
This is the thing
you're measuring,
that you can be using as a
proxy for user happiness.
Are my users happy,
or are they not?
So specifically
for Istio services,
the SLO monitoring
scheme will actually
allow you to pick availability
or latency right there,
because it's aware that--
it's aware of what
an Istio service is.
And it knows the Istio metrics
they use to expose things
like availability and latency.
And you just need to just pick
the kind that you want to use.
If this is not an
Istio service, you
can actually select Other
and essentially pick
any metric within
Google cloud monitoring
to be used as the SLI, or
service level indicator,
for that particular service.
And the last step is to actually
define the service level
objective.
So you may recall
that the service level
the indicator is the metric
that we're going to use
to measure service health.
The service level
objective is the target
that we're going to
put that will actually
tell us whether our
service is healthy enough.
So that's the last
step of the process,
is you pick and set your SLO.
You determine, what is
the level of reliability
that this particular
service needs to deliver.
You specify the time
window over which
you're going to measure it.
You have the option of using
a calendar window or a rolling
window and the length
of that window.
It's then going to show you what
is your SLO compliance looking
like right now, based on the
metric that you've chosen,
your window, and your threshold.
You figure out if
that's what you need,
if that's the right
target for you.
And then you just save the
service, and you're good to go.
So defining an SLO for a
service that you either create
or define yourself, kind
of different metrics
that are already there
for you out of the box,
is fairly straightforward.
In this last part
of the presentation,
I want to talk
about, what do you
do when the metrics that
you want isn't there.
How can you go about adding
custom metrics to Google Cloud
Monitoring in order to use them
as service level indicators?
I want to discuss
four major options.
So again, these are metrics
that aren't there for you out
of the box.
So using load balancer metrics
that Mike already talked about
would be a great place to start.
That's an option for you.
I'm going to talk about
specifically cases where
the metrics just don't exist.
What can you do?
So I'm going to
discuss four options.
Log-based metrics,
using the monitoring
API directly, using a custom
instrumentation library,
like OpenCensus
or OpenTelemetry,
or using Prometheus, which is
a well-known open source time
series monitoring toolkit.
And as I go down
this list, I'm going
to talk about of the basics
of each one, how you might
go about implementing it,
and then talk about some pros
and cons of each so you
can kind of understand,
what are the trade offs of all
these different approaches.
So let's start by talking
about log-based metrics.
Fundamentally, log-based
metrics are the idea
that you can take numerical
values in your logs payloads
and convert them into metrics.
Out of the box, we ship metrics
that are called system logging
metrics.
So these are things that
measure, for example,
log volume ingestion
and other things
so you can understand how
much logging is happening
within the project and
really how much that's
going to cost you.
You can then define two
different metric types
based on your application
of system logs.
Counter metrics would be
just things that kind of
tell you how many times
do you see entries that
match the particular filter.
Distribution metrics
are primarily
what you would use for
SLIs, but you can actually
use them to extract, using
a regular expression,
numerical values from
the logs payload.
So this would be useful for
tracking things like latency.
So if you don't
have a latency SLI,
and maybe that latency is being
written in a log somewhere,
you can use distribution
metrics to do that.
Whereas if you want to do an
availability SLI, where you're
just counting how many errors,
for example, take place,
versus number of total
requests, then you
can use a counter metric.
Obviously the big trade-off
of using log-based metrics
is that this data has
to exist in logs, right?
So you have to have
logs, and you're going
to be paying for those as well.
And if you already have this
information in your logs,
this could be a
great place to start.
You should know that if you're
excluding logs to save on costs
or save on storage, you can't
configure log-based metrics
on logs that are being excluded.
One other thing you should
know is if you want to use SLO
specifically for alerting,
because there can be a delay
between when logs arrive in the
system and when those values
are essentially aggregated
for the purposes of log-based
metrics, if you want to
have very precise learning,
this option may
not actually be--
the data latency may
not be sufficiently
low for that purpose.
So when thinking about
log-based metrics,
the big advantage
of this approach
is that it really
doesn't require you to do
any additional instrumentation.
If logs are already there,
you can just use the data.
The big trade-off is going to
be things like data latency,
but also you need to
have the logs there.
And this could result in
additional charges for you.
Your second option for
custom metric telemetry
instrumentation may be actually
using the monitoring API
to create the metrics directly
within the monitoring deck.
So the way you would do that--
I'm going to walk you through
a basic example of how
you would do that
specifically using Node.js.
So first you set up
the configuration.
This is where you
kind of set up,
what is the metric
you want to write.
It's type, how you'd
actually retrieve it,
and things like that.
The next step is
you create what's
called a metric descriptor.
So this is just kind of--
it provides the API a way to
determine whether the values
need to be written.
Then you create a
data point object.
The data point is going to have
an interval that describes when
this information
is being written,
and then it's going
to have the value.
What's the number?
What's the time series value
you're actually writing?
From there you use
the metric descriptor
to create a time series.
So remember, in Google
Cloud Monitoring,
you can have
multiple time series
against the specific
metric descriptor.
So this is where you create
that particular time series.
And finally, you
actually make a call
to write your data value against
that particular time series.
So as you just
saw, there's a lot
of steps involved if you
want to use the API directly.
The big advantage of
using the Monitoring API
directly is, because you're
interacting at the lowest
possible layer here, you have
all the control you need.
You have full control
over exactly how
the metric descriptor
gets created,
how the time series is
directly related, how
the data points are written.
So if you need that level
of granular control,
using the monitoring API is a
great way to accomplish that.
As you saw, the big trade-off
here is complexity, right?
You have to manage all of
these different things.
So there's probably a
better way to do that.
And what we recommend,
if you actually
want to do this kind
of instrumentation,
is to use these custom
instrumentation libraries.
So you should be aware
that, in the past,
we've recommended OpenCensus,
which is this open source
metric and trace
instrumentation library
that actually came out of the
census library here at Google.
Recently, there's
been announcement
that OpenCensus is actually
merging with the OpenTracing
project in a new project
called OpenTelemetry.
So I'm going to
show you examples
of how to do custom metric
instrumentation, both
in OpenCensus, which is
a project that's been
around for a little bit longer.
And also OpenTelemetry,
which is in your project.
So we take a look
at a code example
of how do we use the OpenCensus
metric instrumentation
library in Node.js to
define a custom metric.
There are basically a couple
of steps that you have to do.
First, you define a measure,
and then you define a view.
If you think about it, back to
going to the Monitoring API,
the view is going to create
the metric descriptor.
The metric is going to create
the specific time series,
and then you're going
to actually write
values against those.
One thing you should
notice is here
at the bottom, where I'm
creating a latency metric,
because I want to
have a latency SLI,
I actually have to
explicitly specify
the buckets of my histogram.
OpenCensus does not allow
you to do that automatically.
It's very explicit
about the fact
that this is something
that I'm required to do
as I write my instrumentation.
So you should be
very cautious when
you're going to be
tracking latency
within your application
using OpenCensus.
You may want to use this
kind of histogram approach.
When you define the
buckets, you need
to define the buckets in a
way that will actually allow
you to create meaningful SLOs.
The buckets have to
be precise enough
to capture the values that
are basically within SLO,
versus those values that
are outside of your SLO.
As a next step, once
I've got the metric,
I can then go and create
my service level objective.
So this is an example
of an API call
that I would use to specify
the service level objective.
You can see that I'm
using a request basis SLO,
and I'm basically saying, I
want to count the requests
within a specific time interval,
whose response threshold is
lower than a value, all
across total requests,
and then I just put a
goal on that SLO, which
is what percentage of
requests have to fall
within that particular time.
When I look in cloud
monitoring, there is my metric,
and then I can
create an SLO again.
So summarizing OpenCensus,
you have to basically create
two different parameters.
You create a measure to
define the type of the metric,
and you have to create the view
to define how that metric is
going to be added.
And then specifically
for latency SLIs,
you need to be careful about
how you define your histogram
buckets to make sure
they're precise enough
to capture the threshold
that you're going
to be defining in your SLI.
Let's now take a
look at an example
of how you do this
with OpenTelemetry,
which is the new project.
When we take a look
at the code, we'll
see that defining the metric
is quite a bit simple.
I don't have to go through
the process of creating
a view and a measure.
I just simply create the
metric, and there I am.
All I have to do
is then essentially
issue a call to
write the balance.
So defining my metrics using
OpenTelemetry is quite a bit
easier, which is obviously good.
The big trade-off,
the thing that's
actually lacking in
OpenTelemetry today,
is this idea of an exporter.
So in OpenCensus, there's
essentially a native exporter
that essentially allows me
to write metrics directly
to the cloud
monitoring back-end.
OpenTelemtry does not
yet have an exporter
for cloud monitoring
for metrics.
And so I have to essentially
use an intermediary
to get my metrics
for my application
into the cloud
monitoring that I can.
In this example, I'm actually
using the Prometheus explorer,
which will also
load the requirement
to set up the Prometheus
integration with Cloud
Monitoring.
But once I've done
that, I can then
go ahead and define
my SLO in the same way
that I did when I
used OpenCensus.
And you can see, the
metric here actually has
the external.googlea
pis.com/prometheus prefix
right?
Because I'm using the
Prometheus exporter,
the metrics actually
make it into the back-end
as Prometheus methods.
So looking at the differences
between OpenCensus
and OpenTelemetry, OpenTelemetry
doesn't make it easier
to declare the metrics.
So the application-side
instrumentation
is, I think, quite
a bit easier to use.
The trade-off there is the
ingestion instrumentation
is a little bit more
complex, because you actually
need to have an additional
layer of infrastructure
to do the ingestion.
And you have to use
Prometheus as an intermediary,
whereas OpenCensus
allows you to just write
those metrics directly.
So looking at the combination
of OpenCensus and OpenTelemetry,
your big advantage really here
is that you write the metrics
directly.
And also, if you want to
get started with distributed
tracing, you actually
use the same library
to do both tracing and metrics,
both in the case of OpenCensus
and OpenTelemetry.
The trade-offs are going
to be, what language
is your application written in.
Does it have support for--
does OpenTelemetry or OpenCensus
support your application
language?
And specifically in the
case of OpenTelemetry,
how do you get the
metrics into the back-end?
Are you going to be willing
to manage the Prometheus
infrastructure to get
that congestion down?
Which obviously brings us to
our last option, which is,
well, we can not use
application-level
instrumentation libraries.
We can just use
Prometheus directly.
So Prometheus is kind of the de
facto standard for monitoring
in the open source
ecosystem and certainly
been something that folks
have been using on Kubernetes
for quite a while.
There's lots of migrations
that are available.
The big trade-off
with Prometheus
is there's essentially
two additional pieces
of infrastructure
that you actually
have to maintain in
order for this to happen.
One is you need the
Prometheus server itself.
So in the case of
applications running in GKE,
you need to have the
Prometheus server deployed
in the same cluster where
your application is.
And then the second
thing you need to do
is you need to actually
patch that server with what's
called the Prometheus
cloud monitoring sidecar.
The sidecar is
just going to take
the metrics from
Prometheus and import them
into cloud monitoring.
So for a specific example of
how this would actually work,
let's take a look
at the code first.
You can see that declaring
metrics in Prometheus
is essentially just as easy
as it was in OpenTelemetry.
This is a very mature library.
It's been out for a long time.
There's lots of examples
of how to do this.
In my example specifically
for latency SLI,
I again have to manually
or explicitly manage
my histogram buckets.
And again, I just
have to make sure
that I'm setting them up in
a sufficiently precise way
such that I can then define
SLOs using those methods.
And here's an example of how
I would write an SLO using
Prometheus metrics.
So summarizing that, you can
use request-based SLIs using
Prometheus metrics--
pretty straightforward.
The big trade-off
there is this need
to maintain additional
infrastructure and a sidecar.
And specifically, to measure
latency using Prometheus,
you do need to be
very precise about how
you define the buckets to
make sure that you have--
that your buckets are
essentially precise enough
to capture those
requests that are
within SLO and those
requests are out of the SLO,
at a bare minimum.
So those are all the
options that we've
gone through as to how you
might go about instrumenting
your grown applications
running in Google Cloud
to expose additional metrics
that you can use for service
level indicators and then
for service level objectives.
To summarize everything
we've talked about today,
just like Mike said
at the beginning,
there is a lot of value
that you can get just
by starting with the
out of the box metrics,
like load balancer metrics
and things like that,
to define SLIs.
If you need to
create your own, you
have to evaluate your options.
There's going to be
trade-offs with each one,
so figure out what
makes sense for you.
But ultimately, it's
really important
that you focus on user
happiness and monitoring,
that you really understand
who are our users, how
do they use our services, how
do our services enable them
to meet their goals, so that you
can really measure and manage
reliability while
focusing on the end user.
Here's what you get
when you do this.
You get SLO dashboards
and cloud monitoring
that looks like
this, where you get
all the SLOs in a single place.
You get any alerts that
are associated with them.
And as we've covered over
the last few minutes,
the SLOs can be
created on metrics
that are ingested automatically,
or all the custom metrics
that we just talked about.
You also get this
in-context information
about things like
metrics and logs
and underlying infrastructure.
So lots of value that you
get by using this approach
to monitoring rather
than just relying
on infrastructure methods.
So thank you so
much for watching.
If this is a topic you have
additional interest in,
here's some other
sessions in this track
that you may want to tune in.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you again for watching.
Mike, thank you so much.
Really appreciate
you being here.
And take care, be safe.
Thank you.